sur le ministre bonsoir bonsoir du roi
monsieur le ministre dans le 30
septembre dans deux jours donc les
enseignants à une partie des enseignants
qui sont nombreux vont encore débrayé ce
n'est toujours pas réglée bien sûr les
nids de ces négociations là il ya
énormément d'inquiétude dans le réseau
de l'éducation les parents les
enseignants
qu'est ce que vous dites aux parents qui
vont encore une fois à les appuyer les
enseignants le premier tome feront le
tour des écoles
vous leur dites quoi là je leur dis
d'abord que c'est leur droit c'est le
droit des parents de quiconque de
pouvoir s'associer là pour manifester je
pensais pas du tout le problème pour moi
l'enjeu vous savez bien c'est une année
budgétaire difficile on savait que ce
serait un automne plus difficile compte
tenu notamment le conte est en
négociation en ce moment avec nos
syndicats donc on savait que ça va être
plus difficile
moi et mon gouvernement ont négocié pour
l'ensemble de la population en ce moment
avec le syndicat est-ce que vous
continuez à dire c'est pas clair qu
est-ce qu on continue à dire que les
services aux élèves ne sont pas touchés
je vais répéter ce que j'ai dit je suis
d'être plus clair possible là dessus et
une sensibilité en ce moment que je
comprends qu'ils très forte par rapport
aux élèves en difficulté d'apprentissage
ou à l'efb handicapés ou en difficulté
d'adaptation
nous avons maintenu cette année malgré
l'effort budgétaire qui demande et nous
avons maintenu totalement l'enveloppent
pour ses enfants
je comprends qu on en voudrait plus qui
aurait d'autres projets je pense que ça
a été responsable de notre part de
maintenir cette enveloppe
mais quand la suite et on comprend jeu
sous fond juste là dessus monsieur mines
excusez moi mais coûts et la csdm nous
annonce qui à 68 professionnels
orthopédagogue de -6 10% de leurs
effectifs
donc comment on ne peut pas toujours
jamais aux élèves en difficulté de façon
générale à ce moment là oui parce que la
csdm depuis longtemps est dans une
situation problématique
elle est en situation où elle doit
redresser ses finances
on a eu un rapport très important le
printemps dernier un rapport indépendant
j'insiste là dessus qu'ils monteraient
jusqu'à quel point il y avait des enjeux
de gouvernance de saine administration
dans la csdm on demande à ccm de faire
des efforts en ce moment pour se
redresser pour être finalement comme les
autres commissions scolaires au québec
ce qu'il peut encore vous savez comme
depuis plusieurs années là bas mais
jouer mais je répète ma question il ya
quand même
soixante huit professionnels de -1 qui
ont été coupés à la csdm sauf pour les
élèves dans les classes de côte des
neiges de heureusement ce sont des gens
de moins pour aider les élèves entre
autres en difficulté oui mais ça n'a pas
de rapport avec des compressions
budgétaires de nos gouvernements c'est
ça qu'il faut bien faire comprendre aux
gens de la cr est dans une situation de
redressement elle fait beaucoup moins
bien c'est une large bureaucratie qui
fait beaucoup moins bien que les
commissions scolaires proches voisines
on lui demande de se redresser de faire
progressivement
il ya une façon de le faire il ya eu un
rapport qui a été déposée pour lui
montrer le chemin pour y arriver mais
elle est dans une situation toute
particulière au québec mais musulmane
est excusez moi qu'on va passer à un
autre sujet là tu mets là j'entends les
parents qui vous en attendez qu'ils
hurlent à la maison en train de vous
mettez ça sur le dos d'une mauvaise
gestion d'une commune du grosses
commissions scolaires mais dans les
faits il ya 68 professionnels tulle
il sait pas des gestionnaires il
brassait pas des papiers y aller voir
les jeunes élèves dans les classes
oui mais on a toujours demandé aussi à
la csdm comme on l'a demandé à
l'ensemble des commissions scolaires
cette année de faire un effort mais de
faire un effort intelligent et de
protéger les services
je ne veux pas commenter exactement sur
le code à ccm et ses décisions et très
clairement au québec cette année dans
une situation plus difficile au niveau
budgétaire
on voit des commissions scolaires qui
protège et services qui sont bien
administrer et on voit d'autres
commissions scolaires qui en arrachent
dont la discute et je le vois bien c'est
pour ça qu'on va déposer prochainement
un projet de loi qui va redéfinir les
rôles et les responsabilités leur année
hier du reynou ce cas là c'est très
important il n'y a pas que la csdm qui
par ailleurs a dû ajuster ses prix
journées pédagogiques vous le savez on a
donné des exemples dont 1/1 heureusement
ou des jeunes qui avaient payé 27 dollar
donc leurs parents qui avaient pu payer
27 dollars elle est jouée dans la cour
avec des des jeux des animaux des
serpentins et caetera et ceux qui
avaient pas pays regardé par la fenêtre
et devait rester dans l'école
est ce que c'est ça qu'on veut au québec
monsieur le ministre non j'ai déjà dit
que c'était moi j'ai trouvé ça
complètement stupide je vous le dis
quand j'ai vu ce qu'on avait fait aux
yeux aux enfants de placer les enfants
dans une situation comme ça j'ai trouvé
ça malheureux et il n'y a pas de raison
de faire ça ça n'a aucun rapport avec
quelques compressions que ce soit c'est
un manque de jugement pour bien dire ça
arrive parfois un manque de jugement
d'ailleurs parce que les organisateurs
l'ont reconnu que tu as une erreur de
leur part et qu'ils allaient ils
n'allaient plus dont reconnaître ce
genre de placer les enfants plus tôt
dans ce type de situation était tout à
fait regrettable vous dites ça n'a rien
à voir que les compressions ce sont les
compressions qui fort c'est quelque
chose qu'on est allé chercher des moyens
de financer non non non non soyons
prudents là dessus a toujours eu des
activités organisées pour les journées
pédagogiques pour les enfants moi j'ai
des enfants des cinq qui sont passés par
le secteur public que j'ai vu ces
journées-là organisé je pense faire en
sorte qu'elle soit dans un prix qui est
correct pour que les enfants puissent
participer au plus grand nombre
mais faire ce qu'on a fait là sa place
et de sous le nez des enfants des
activités auxquelles ils n'ont pas accès
je pense que tout le monde ont reconnu
que c'était une erreur de jugement très
bien les principaux intéressés ça n'a
aucun rapport avec des quelques
compositions que ce soit je faisais
référence à cette grève du 30 septembre
j'ai une petite question sur les
négociations pour vous monsieur le
ministre
est ce que vous allez oui ou non est ce
que vous demandez
oui ou non une augmentation du ratio
après la deuxième année au primaire là
pour les enseignants ce qui est en jeu
en ce moment au niveau des ratios des
discussions que l'on a avec les
syndicats c'est de donner de la
flexibilité et nos demandes ne s'est pas
uniquement les deux
en 2010 de discussions elles ont été
préparées par des cadres scolaires par
des directeurs d'établissements qui
année après année travail avec les
enseignants travaillent pour former des
groupes classe et qui nous disent
toujours la même chose s'il y avait un
peu plus de fluxys est-ce que ça vous
protéger ces fossiles à ce nom alors
protégé est ce possible diminué c'est un
enjeu diminué notamment pour les petits
et les milieux défavorisés
les ratios et bien sûr compensée par une
augmentation là où on a moins besoin des
ratios que l'on nous avons actuellement
donc c'est vraiment là c'est la question
ce n'est pas d'augmenter pour tout le
monde mais n'augmente et là où il ya une
marge
ouh là où ne sonnera pas l'impact pour
la réussite scolaire et diminuer là où
ça va vraiment un impact c'est à dire
chez les petits et aussi chez les
milieux défavorisés c'est ça qui est
autour de la table monsieur n'y a qu'un
remonte une discussion vous avez pu
avoir des effets un colloque en fin de
semaine des spécialistes et à carouge
est allé dans une vraie salle de classe
ce soit dans la région de montréal ou
ailleurs vous asseoir avec des
enseignants pour qu'ils vous parlent du
ratio des problèmes de suivre chaque
élève avec des problèmes dans la région
de montréal en plus souvent ils ne
parlent pas le français quand ils
arrivent très tôt à quel moment vous
êtes ali est ce que vous allez allez
rencontrer les vrais plus vraiment qui
travaillent dans les écoles bien sûr
j'ai encore à tous les jours ça te donne
comme ça je suis reconnu maintenant les
enseignants bien de le voir encore hier
j'étais je faisais des courses c'est une
enseignante qui me voient en parler
cette situation on a discuté d'ailleurs
c'était assez intéressant parce que je
lui expliquer notre point de vue c'était
un point de vue qu'elle ne connaissait
pas
donc étaient intéressés à connaître
pourquoi nous avions par exemple sur la
question des ratios ce que nous
envisageons ce n'est pas du tout
d'augmenter pour tout le monde mais de
sens de faire en sorte que d'empêcher
les plus petits
il ya une amélioration de la situation
qui était à augmenter là où c'est
possible donc moi je continue je suis
toujours en discussion avec des
enseignants ce matin j'étais dans un
groupe communautaire qui s'occupe d'eux
dead aux jeunes en difficulté au niveau
de l'aide aux devoirs je suis très très
près de ce milieu je suis bien
l'occurrence qui se passe je viens ce
milieu j'ai des amis qui sont encore
dont j'ai pas de tout déconnecté de la
situation actuelle s'éliminer sainte
hermine en jarez mais comparé le plus
long terme on va y revenir une autre
fois en terminale c'est un dossier qu'on
suit depuis dix ans nous ici au
téléjournal c'est que ces écoles
illégales juive notamment
on a eu tous vos prédécesseurs et qui
nous ont expliqué que c'était
intolérable qu'ils allaient mettre fin à
ça le dernier en ligne il ya un homme
monsieur bolduc
un an plus tard ya rien qui a changé sur
le thème oui un reportage qu'est ce que
vous nous dites là ce qu'on va laisser
des petits enfants québécois qui vivent
ici sans instruction publique
non il n'y a pas de petits enfants elle
ne sont pas sans instruction publiée oui
et les gestions d'avallon attention les
lignes de base ils y reçoivent paul pour
les soins faisant attention là parce que
ces présentations ces écoles sont
suivies il ya des cas plus de plus
radicaux ou là il ya un problème on
intervient et il ya des codes sont dans
des zones grille je reconnais dans les
zones grises à ce moment-là nous
priorisons toujours l'intérêt de
l'enfant mais comprenez-moi bien que je
t'ai population me comprennent là dessus
l'intérêt de l'enfant à court terme mais
aussi à long terme alors nous
intervenons toujours en pensant que les
parents si possible doivent être dans le
coup doivent être un appui à nos actions
c'est pour ça que c'est délicat mais
lorsqu'on il s'agit de quoi vraiment
grossier ou on est vraiment à
l'extérieur de tout le régime scolaire
l'on doit d'intervenir avec plus de
force
l'école religieuse dont on parlait là ça
fait ils sont à l'extérieur du calme et
on leur avait donné un an pour que la
commission scolaire anglophone viennent
donner des cours de base français
anglais mathématiques etc
ce n'est toujours pas le cas dormal
question clooney [ __ ] mais je vous
laisse 30 secondes
est ce que vous allez à jouer ou non ted
ans le code cette école-là on a agi je
peux donc très clairement non on a
demandé à la commission scolaire de
sang-mêlé d'appuyer les enfants il ya un
cadre c'est très particulier comme
situation je le reconnais
un cadre qui a été accepté par toutes
les parties
et dans ce cas là les enfants vont avoir
accès à la scolarisation très bien
monsieur minutes c'est tout un conte à
merci vous avons parlé on va suivre cet
automne ce sera un des grands dossiers
cette cette rentrée puis cette
négociation avec les enseignants les
syndicats
c'est très bien je vous remercie
beaucoup au revoir merci